مقاطعه بالجراد الروسيه تحت مرمى النيران
الاوكرانيه ليس الامر جديدا فاستهداف
المنطقه الروسيه المحاذيه للحدود الشماليه
الاوكرانيه بدا منذ الشهر الاول للحرب لكن
الهجمات تعاظمت كمن ونوعا بالجراد تقع
جنوب غرب روسيا لها حدود مع اوكرانيا
طولها 450 كيلومترا تقريبا تحاذي مقاطعه
ولا تزيد المسافه بين وسط برجراد ووسط خار
كيد على خمسينات
تحمل بالجراد اهميه استراتيجيه لروسيا
تشكل المقاطعه خط امداد
وتحرك رئيسي للقوات الروسيه وشكلت بوابه
لعبور الجنود الروسي الى شمال اوكرانيا
منتصف شهر ايار مايو اقر حاكم بالجراد
فياتشي سلاف جلاتك اوف بدخول ما سماها
مجموعه تخريب واستطلاع اوكرانيه
على اقليم جرايفورونسكي في المقاطعه
وبينما نفت كياف تورطها بالهجمات اعلنت
مجموعه تطلق على نفسها اسم الفيلق الروسي
الحر واخرى باسم فيلق المتطوعين الروسي
تنفيذ التوغل الذي لم يقتصر على بالجراد
بل وصلت المجموعه الى مقاطعه كورسك
المجاوره لكن موسكو ترفض الاعتراف بوجود
هاتين المجموعتين
تطورات فرضت سؤالا هل انتقلت المعركه الى
داخل روسيا سؤال ملح لاسيما مع حديث
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عن ان ما
يجري محاوله لزعزعه الوضع داخل روسيا
ومخاطبا مجلس الامن القومي الروسي بالقول
يجب ان نفعل ما بوسعنا لمنعهم تحت اي ظرف
اما رئيس قوات فاجنر يفجن بريكوجين فيصف
الوضع في بنكراد بالفوضى التي قد تحتم
تدخل قواته التي تعرف بالمرتزقه في القريب
العاجل لحمايه السكان ان لم تقم وزاره
الدفاع بذلك ليبقى التساؤل الابرز اين
تموضعت القوات الروسيه التي انسحبت من
خاركيف وسومي في اب اغسطس الماضي وما هو
سبب عدم نشرها في المقاطعات الحدوديه
لاسيما بالجراد وكورسك
[موسيقى]